What would you suggest for students to be studying in school
so that they could be prepared to contribute to this area?
I think getting a good background in basic computer science,
including a mathematical background like discrete mathematics
and programming and so on is important.
Also nowadays knowing systems is important because there are lots and lots of hidden
power of modern computer systems such as parallelism, concurrency,
various levels of memory hierarchy, and so on,
which is something that clearly doesn't capture very well,
but you can get several orders of improvements in your algorithm
by taking advantage of this.
I highly recommend the Easley-Kleinberg book called Networks, Crowds, and Markets.
I have the book jackets here, so you can see it.
But it was published by Cambridge University Press in 2010.
A free version of it is available on the internet, so you don't have to buy it.
Again, it's called Networks, Crowds, and Markets.
It's a great read.
They went to great pains to have very few Greek letters,
so they are just trying to get the concepts to you.
Also, at the end of very chapter it has like advanced materials,
so if you want to delve more into it and they have beautiful citations
and lots and lots of reference, but it's a great, great book.
Knowledge of algorithms is good, looking at social networks in a different way.
Not just as social network but actually starting to look at how social networks actually work.
There are papers that come out very regularly,
and you don't need to go to like Google Scholar.
There are different industry websites that keep track of social networks, like Mashable,
that you can actually look at, and they sometimes send out very nice analysis posts
on what's actually going on,
and just keeping yourself abreast of this will make it more advantageous
if you are interviewing, because you will be able to actually speak,
use the right wordings and will also get you to actually appreciate
the math and the science behind the networks.
I see. So, spending a certain amount of time wasting time on the Internet,
is actually a really useful thing. Not all the time, mind you.
Yeah, in this case it's good wasting. &gt;&gt;Yes. Good wasting.